شكراً لكم
صباح الخير للجميع
الرئيس ماكرون ، إنه لمن
دواعي سروري البالغ أن أرحب بكم الفضاء هو
مكان جديد للصراع
بالفعل ولدينا لاعبين مجانين في هذا
الفضاء
أيضًا ولدينا Rock State هناك
ولدينا هجمات هجينة جديدة  وأعتقد
أنه مهم جدًا معًا
لأننا نشارك هذا التاريخ ولدينا
نفس الالتزام والارتباط
بالعلم والتقدم ولكننا نتشارك
وكذلك نفس القيم
الديمقراطية ولا أريد أن أكرر لأنني
أريدنا  من أجل المشاركة
في الحوار الشامل حول
الفضاء ، وقد اتفقنا على تطوير
قواعد ومعايير محددة في القواعد والمعايير الدولية للفضاء
،
وترحب الولايات
المتحدة بالطبع ويسعدها أن فرنسا
ووكالة الفضاء الأوروبية ستواصلان
عملياتهما في  محطة الفضاء الدولية
حتى عام 2030.